Speaker 1: We have yet another example now
of failed former President Donald Trump being
given the opportunity to just cleanly condemn
the Russian President Vladimir Putin and his
invasion of Ukraine.
And he doesn't do it.
Last night, the former failed president was
interviewed by Fox News propagandist Sean
Hannity.
And in a moment, we're going to get to some
of this windmill stuff.
Trump still very confused about windmills,
and we're going to do a little bit of a deeper
dove into windmills and birds.
But before we get to that, here's the opportunity
Hannity just says it is this evil just tees
up an easy one for Trump to condemn Putin.
And Trump doesn't delivering another one of
these words salads.
Take a listen to this.
Ask you the last time you were on whether
you think that this is evil in our time.
Speaker 2: Do you believe this is evil in
our
Speaker 1: time, right?
Speaker 4: I think in a hundred years people
are going to look back and they're going to
say, How did we stand back?
And Naito stand backwards.
Speaker 1: So that's a criticism of Naito
and of Biden understand.
Hannity says it is this evil is Putin.
Evil is what Russia's doing evil.
And he goes.
The history books are not going to look kindly
at Naito and the United States and Biden.
Now also remember, well, let's play a little
more.
Speaker 4: In many ways I've called a paper
tiger.
Don't forget I rebuilt Naito because when
I became president, the first thing I noticed
when I went there to the first meeting was
that most of the countries were not paying
or were paying far less than they were supposed
to.
There were only eight out of twenty eight
countries that were paid in the United States
was not only one of them.
We were making up the deficit in order to
protect Europe.
We were paying possibly 80 percent of Naito
to protect them.
And then they take advantage of us yet on
trade, because on trade, they're every bit
as bad as China.
They treated us very badly on trade.
We changed a lot of that around, but they
were very tough on trade.
I asked Angela Merkel how many Chevrolet's
guys remember.
Speaker 1: The question was, is it evil what
Putin is doing?
And Trump's criticizing Naito, implicitly
criticizing Biden for not doing enough and
now criticizing Angela Merkel.
Speaker 4: Are you selling this in Munich
or Berlin?
And she looked at me, Well, probably no.
And I said, You're exactly right.
None.
And yet we had the Mercedes Benz and the Volkswagen
said all of them.
We had all of the German companies and the
same thing with farmers.
Our farmers sell virtually nothing to Europe.
You take a look at.
Speaker 1: How crazy is that?
I mean, how bonkers is that?
It is, is is Putin's invasion evil?
Why aren't Americans American cars being sold
in Germany?
That's really bad, and NATO's bad and Biden's
bad, and by the way, we Trump seems obsessed
with why you don't see people driving around
in Chevy's in Germany.
Guys, I hate to be critical of American industry,
but like if you can get a Volkswagen locally
produced, if you can get a Mercedes or an
Audi locally produced, why are you going to
say get me an American Chevy?
I mean, Germany has very good cars.
I get it anyway.
So another opportunity to just plainly cleanly
criticize Putin's invasion and Trump doesn't
do it.
Now, there was another really wacky moment
in this interview which is not getting as
much attention.
Listen to what Donald Trump had to say about
bald eagles as he says being killed by windmills.
Trump is very much against wind farms.
He says the noise causes cancer.
Not true.
And listen to what he had to say.
Speaker 4: Windmills, because they're killing
eagles.
They're killing the bald eagle and other eagles
and other birds.
And we have these windmills all over the place
and the environmentalists pretend they love
them.
But they're really hurting our country.
They're driving down values.
They're just absolutely killing us, one of
the most expensive forms of energy.
The turbines are all made in China or Germany,
so they get the advantage of that.
It's just ridiculous.
But the real problem?
Speaker 1: Yeah, do so.
So this has been studied in this.
Trump has been repeating this for years, and
many on the right have been repeating this
about wind farms.
Do windmills kill some birds?
Yes, they do.
They do.
Windmills kill from about two hundred and
thirty thousand to three hundred and thirty
thousand birds per year.
Wow.
OK, well, that that's significant, right?
Well, maybe cell and radio towers cause nearly
seven million bird deaths per year.
Well, wait, wait a second.
The wind farms kill two hundred and fifty
thousand, call it, and the cell and radio
towers kill seven million.
Yes.
And they never talk about that.
Cats.
OK.
I know a lot of cat owners don't like cats.
Kill one point four to three point seven billion
birds a year billion with a B..
OK.
So windmills are having no statistically significant
effect on the bird population.
But you know what?
Maybe I'm being unfair because I'm comparing
bird deaths from an energy generation mechanism
to other types of bird deaths.
OK.
Well, if you consider the oil and gas fields,
oil and gas fields kill 500000 to a million
birds per year already, and you never hear
about it.
OK, so this is a completely hypocritical talking
point.
Everything we do has an effect.
Do you wear a cotton?
Cotton requires a lot of water.
The water that goes to make cotton clothing
leads to frogs and salamanders dying because
they have no environment anymore.
The water is gone.
OK, I mean, so we'll maybe switch to synthetic
clothing.
Oh, but that's that.
Those are oil derivatives in many cases.
And then you've got the birds can.
These things are complicated, but one thing
we know for sure is that the bird death toll
from windmills is statistically insignificant
compared to all the other things that we have
an industry that are killing birds now.
In terms of eagles, there's really no specific
data on how many bald eagles are being killed
by wind turbines.
The estimate is that in total, about 100 eagles
a year die from wind turbines.
In theory, some of the 100 or bald eagles,
I don't know.
It depends.
You'd have to look more.
We don't have that data, but way more eagles
die from other things humans do.
If you care about the Eagles, do you know
how many eagles die from hitting cars?
Do you know how many eagles die from eating
leftover LED?
I don't know if it's called buckshot or just
shot, you know, ordinance of sword ammunition,
spend it used in eagles, eat it and then they
die, or eagles hitting electrified power lines.
Well, shit.
Shouldn't we be burying power lines?
Oh no, that's too expensive.
We can't do that.
So this is nonsense.
It's nonsense.
But as is often the case, there's like a tiny
it's somewhere there's like a tiny little
kernel of something true about it.
And then they fixate on it, and then they
blow it up and then they repeat it uncritically.
So a very strange interview there with Sean
Hannity